l'hebdo politique bonsoir et bienvenue
dans l'hebdo politique votre rendez vous
du dimanche soir sur radio sensations en
association avec les vestes en dix huit
épisodes 214 mon invité ce soir et la
porte parole du parti animalistes
catherine helayel
[Musique]
les politiques
catherine helayel bonsoir oui bonsoir
vous est avocate et avait cofondée en
2013 l'association animal justice et
droits en 2016 le parti animalistes est
fondée en vous en êtes aujourd'hui co
présidente et porte parole des laiteries
la candidate du parti à l'élection
présidentielle l'objectif du parti est
de faire progresser la cause animale
dans les débats politiques alors créé
officiellement en 2016 quelles étaient
les raisons de la création de ce parti
alors en fait donc qu'on a travaillé il
a été créé officiellement en 2016 mais
il ya eu deux ans de préparation avant
fin au moins un en préparation donc on
s'est aperçus parce qu'on vient tous de
milieux militants et d'association on
s'est aperçu en fait que
pour eux pour que les autres partis
politiques puissent s'emparer de la
cause animale pour que ça devienne
vraiment un sujet politique il fallait
créer son propre parti politique parce
que le travail des associations s'il
n'est pas relayé par des modifications
de la loi et bien j'allais dire ça tombe
à l'eau donc comme aucun parti politique
n'avait jamais pris la cause animale au
sérieux si je puis dire il fallait qu'un
parti politique puisse le faire un petit
peu comme à l'époque 74 où on a eu le
premier parti écologie et depuis lors je
dis pas que ça a marché sur mais depuis
tous les partis politiques se sont
emparés de l'écologie en 2019 aux
élections européennes votre parti a
recueilli 490 mille voix soit presque 2
22% devant les listes upr où les
patriotes un peu plus connus c'était un
score j'imagine très satisfaisant pour
vous très rageant c'est un score très
satisfaisant d'autant plus que si on
replace dans le contexte c'est à dire un
parti qui n'étaient pas connus qui
n'avaient pas de moyens donc qu'ils
n'avaient pas de de télé pratiquement
n'a été jamais on n'a jamais ou
pratiquement deux fois était invité dans
les médias donc on sait effectivement ça
a créé la surprise d'autant plus qu'on a
connus on n'avait pas les moyens de
mettre 100 % des bulletins de vote
partout donc il y avait 20 % il y avait
des endroits où c'était pas mal répartie
donc effectivement c'est c'est un
résultat qui qui était attendu par nous
mais inattendu compte tenu des
circonstances que je viens d'évoquer et
notamment du fait qu'il n'y avait pas de
médiatisation hélène tout ya été
investie candidate pour le parti
dans la campagne présidentielle pour
2022 alors comment est-ce qu'elle a été
désignée est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter votre candidature oui alors en
fait j'aurais quand même revenir sur /
en fait on avait décidé au parti
animalistes de ne pas mettre de
personnes une personnalité en avant donc
il ya des porte parole mais on voulait
pas que l'image du parti soit
représentée par une personne d'où les
animaux sur nos affiches donc lorsque
par contre en revance la présidentielle
et bien comme c'est une personne qui
doit être mise en avant donc on ad on a
lancé un appel à à nos adhérents enfin
sur les personnes qui travaillent au
parti animalistes qu'on a et
lnd qui a été choisi à l'unanimité
et vous la connaissez depuis longtemps
alors moi je connais les nourrit depuis
plus de dix ans puisqu'on a cofondé j'ai
cofondé avec l l'association animal lui
si ses droits et justement puisque vous
m'en donnez l'occasion j'aimerais quand
même saluer la personne parce que je
sais pas si on se rend compte mais elle
continue de travailler on vous avait
beaucoup quand même de deux hommes
politiques qui en ce moment ne se
consacrent qu'à la campagne
présidentielle donc c'est quelqu'un qui
continue son travail d'avocat qui
continue maintenant sa campagne dont qui
mène les deux de front qui est engagée
complètement désintéressés qui est
vraiment une personne qui est humble
compétentes et qui à la limite qui va
proposer un programme dont les
principales les principaux bénéficiaires
ne votent pas
ça veut dire qu'elle a beaucoup de
courage elle a beaucoup de courage donc
vraiment c je salue ce salut il ntumi
pour pour eux pour ce qu'elle fait
pour le parti animalistes au pouvoir
confirmer cette candidature il faut
récolter 500 parrainages d'élus est ce
que vous êtes confiant pour
arrivé alors au jour d'aujourd'hui on
approche des 3 100 parrainages
donc il nous en manque encore 200 ce qui
est quand même déjà j'allais dire énorme
pour un parti pour une personne qui se
présente pour la première fois je sais
plus entendait d'autres d'autres
politiques qui disait pas par exemple
pour tous une fois qui expliquait qu'en
fait il s'était représenté une deuxième
fois parce que comme il était inconnu la
première fois et bien c'était très
compliqué donc on a deux obstacles on a
d'une part et les hnwi n'est pas connu
le parti animalistes est connu mais pas
hélène tweed donc il fallait associer
les deux et puis la seconde difficulté
c'est qu'effectivement les parrainages
ne sont plus anonyme donc on a beaucoup
de maires on a à peu près enfin 200
personnes au parc animalistes qui
travaille sur la collecte il ya beaucoup
de mères qui nous disent je vous offre
j'aimerais bien parrainer parce
qu'effectivement ils ont compris que le
parrainage n'était pas un soutien
j'aimerais bien vous parrainez mais
comme c'est pas anonyme on hésite encore
des pressions d'intel il ya même eu
l'air mois la subvention il ya même bond
et des versions dont leurs conseils dans
le conseil municipal des chasseurs et
cetera donc ils n'ont pas envie de 2
alors que le parrainage n'est pas un
soutien et vous avez d'ailleurs des
politiques comme le notamment monsieur
bayrou qui récemment a dit il faudrait
faire une réserve de parrainage pour les
partis politiques légitimes alors il a
dû estimer que le parti fln tout n'était
pas légitime parce qu'apparemment il
nous a pas citées pour sa réserve de
parrainage mais bon si monsieur bayrou
vous m'entendez on va bien on considère
que la candidature d'hélène tout y est
parfaitement légitime mais le principal
objectif est de faire progresser la
cause animale dans le débat public parce
que le parti n liste a vocation à
gouverner alors au jour d'aujourd'hui
j'ai envie de dire non 1 mais c'est une
question vous pourriez poser à beaucoup
d'autres candidats qui se présentent et
on sait très bien aujourd'hui que il ya
trois peut-être trois quatre parties qui
peuvent aller accéder au second tour les
autres n'ont donc ses autres partis ont
déjà certes des élus mais ils ne vont
pas être il pourrait être appelé dans un
gouvernement mais le parti ne font pas
être élu et on leur dit pas pourquoi
vous êtes là donc effectivement on n'a
pas aujourd'hui
1 effectivement on y réalise thaïlande
twist c'est très bien qu'elle ne va pas
être élue présidente de la république il
n'en demeure pas moins que plus on va
parler de la cause animale plus les
autres partis politiques vont s'en
emparer parce qu'en fait on a réalisé
que la seule chose que certains partis
politiques comprennent c'est baala ils
vont nous prendre des voix et donc bah
on a fini par parler enfin par mettre
cette pression sur les autres partis
politiques et ça a marché
le parti animalistes ce qu'il est de
droite ou de gauche on sait que en
politique on aime bien classés les
parties pour y voir plus clair alors
certains vous voient comme un parti
satellite d'europe écologie les verts
vous avez un conseiller régional en ile
de france guy préval qui a été élu sur
la liste d'union de la gauche au second
tour alors doit-on en déduire que vous
êtes en partie plutôt à gauche alors pas
du tout justement alors nous sommes un
parti trans partisan parce que nous
estimons que la cause animale elle est
au delà elle doit être au delà des
clivages politiques et pour cette
alliance 6 effectivement on a eu un
autre élu mais on avait d'autres
personnes qui se sont présentées sur des
listes de droite et sur des listes de
gauche notamment par exemple pour les
municipales où effectivement
malheureusement on n'a pas les moyens et
vu le système électoral on ne pouvait
pas être se présenter seul on a fait des
alliances avec des partis de droite et
de gauche dont les têtes de liste était
animalistes compatible bien évidemment
donc nous ne tenons absolument à rester
trans partisan pourquoi parce que si on
s'était positionné à droite ou à gauche
et que les électeurs avaient voté pour
nous on ne serait pas s'ils ont voté
pour la cause animale on ne serait pas
là on peut vraiment et les autres
parties peuvent se dire mon sens ils ont
fait 2,3 pour cent mais ça veut dire
qu'il ya au moins cinq cent mille
français qui sont prêts à voter pour un
parti qui est trans partisan et dont
effectivement et monothématique de
manière directe et indirecte mais j'y
reviendrai si vous me posez la question
même si sur le thème de la cause animale
le 30 novembre 2000 21 l'assemblée
nationale a voté
une loi visant à lutter contre la
maltraitance animale et à renforcer les
liens entre les animaux et les hommes
alors on va rentrer dans le détail avec
quelques mesures mais globalement qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de cette loi et
de la manière dont ils ont traité le
sujet les députés globalement on se
réjouit toujours quand il ya des mesures
qui sont favorables aux animaux je sais
que j'aimerais rappeler d'ailleurs que
la pratique les mesures qui ont été
des sites qui ont été ensuite voté par
l'assemblée était déjà là était dans
notre programme depuis 2016 on donc on
est content bien évidemment des mesures
qui ont été prises simplement
c'est pas suffisant parce que ne sont
concernés que les animaux domestiques et
une partie des animaux sauvages dans le
cadre du divertissement que les animaux
qui sont en majorité par en nombre ceux
qui souffrent le plus a guère les
animaux d'élevage ont été complètement
exclue de cette loi est de la même
manière que la chasse donc il ya un
début maintenant il faut voir quand
est-ce que ça va vraiment être appliquée
il faut voir la volonté politique
derrière c'est vrai que les délais qui
ont été il ya des choses qui ont été
faites on est content ça va dans la
bonne direction mais ça ne suffit pas au
jour d'aujourd'hui ça c'est clair les
chiens et les chats ne pourront plus
être vendus en animalerie à partir de
2024 la vente ou la cession d'animaux de
compagnie seront interdits aux mineurs
sont des mesures que vous avez alors
nous au parti animalistes on va beaucoup
plus loin que ça on souhaite
l'interdiction de tirer un profit de la
vente de tous les animaux pas simplement
des chats et des chiens c'est à dire
qu'il faudrait bien évidemment que les
anime les animaleries eux proposent des
chiens qui viennent qui viendrait des
refuse mais qu'on interdise tout tous
les animaux et pas simplement les chats
et les chiens il ya aussi la vente
d'animaux exotiques dena des poissons
d'ornement se demande ce que ce que ça
fait là des oiseaux dans les cages donc
oui c'est un début mais c'est pas
suffisant pareil il faudrait aussi
interdire toutes les ventes cette fois
pas par par internet donc là le bon coin
etc ça va ça va dans le bon sens on va
pas on va pas dire le contraire ça va
dans le bon sens mais bon voilà bah
parce que je suis un mais c'est à dire
que c'est pas laisser pas non c'est pas
suffisant gagner le texte initial
prévoyait une obligation pour le maire
de faire stériliser les chats sauvages
sur sa commune alors finalement elle a
été remplacée par une expérimentation
sur cinq ans et une action coordonnée
contre la prolifération des chats
errants par l'état et les collectivités
territoriales
quand vous regrettez à notre programme
on veut qu'ils aient effectivement une
obligation de stérilisation des chats
mais on veut que les mairies puisse
aider et être aidé financièrement
au jour d'aujourd'hui qui travaillent ce
sont les associations sur le terrain
donc quitte rappelé chats errants on a à
peu près alors il ya des chiffres qui
varient entre 5 et 11 peut-être 11 en a
pas mais enfin il ya une commission qui
a été créé pour justement comptabiliser
les chats errants parce qu'il ya des
associations qui nous disent y en a cinq
d'autres 11 millions en tout cas y en a
énormément et si on ne les stérilisent
pas on va effectivement vers une
prolifération il faut savoir que être un
chat errant c'est une vie terrible un
temps qu'il ya une moyenne de vie deux
ans ils sont malades ils se font écraser
cherche la nourriture donc on ne dise
pas que et chats errants c'est une belle
vie 1 donc il faudrait généraliser que
tout les d'ailleurs les chats qui soit
rap et une soif stérilisés ensuite une
fois qu'on les a stérilisé deux
solutions soit effectivement on arrive à
les adopter soit si on les remet sur
site il faut pouvoir les protéger c'est
à dire un endroit on va pouvoir les
nourrir les attrapés pour les soigner
c'est pas simplement les stériliser ses
pouvoir prévoir comment va ensuite
s'occuper d'eux une fois qu'on va les
avoir relâché sur site pour ceux qui ne
seront pas adoptées parce que
malheureusement la majorité des
personnes souhaitent adopter des chatons
le texte durcit aussi les sanctions en
cas d'actes de cruauté envers un animal
domestique un amendement transforme en
délit le fait de donner volontairement
la mort un animal domestique ou
apprivoisé par des exceptions sont
prévues notamment contre les traditions
locales je pense par exemple à la
corrida j'imagine que vous seriez allé
beaucoup plus loin là encore
dans le programme initial on avait
demandé d'une part que les sanctions
soient augmentés et puis surtout
effectivement que le fait de donner à la
donner la mort
d'un animal alors sans actes de cruauté
avant était simplement une contravention
terre que tu un lapin sans le faire
souffrir c'était pas un lapin lapin
domestique ça n'a pas sauvage non
c'était un simple une simple
contravention donc c'est une bonne chose
que ce soit devenu un délit c'est une
bonne chose qu'on ait augmenté les
sanctions ce qu'il faut aussi c'est se
donner les moyens derrière c'est à dire
que si ya pas de parquet spécialisé s'il
n'y a pas une police si la gendarmerie
il n'y a pas une police spécialisés etc
on ne poursuit pas effectivement les
gens parce qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui on
peut on peut condamner jusqu'à deux ans
mais les sanctions ne sont pas ne sont
jamais appliquées donc trois ans c'est
bien mais il faut se donner les moyens
derrière et pour que pour que c'est
effectivement ces sanctions puissent
être réellement appliquer le texte
prévoit la fin des animaux sauvages dans
les cirques itinérants et les défis
narnia concrètement les spectacles de
dauphins ou d'orques seront interdits à
partir de 2026 cette fois il sera mis
fin à leur détention et reproduction en
captivité alors d'ici 2028 la détention
et le spectacle d'animaux sauvages dans
les cirques itinérants sera elle
interdite en france cela concerne c'est
pour une estimation 850 animaux de
cirque 21 dauphin quatre orques et 5
montreurs d'ours alors que penser which
actuel des choses déjà nous on souhaite
que ça soit l'interdiction de tous les
animaux dans les cirques parce que les
animaux ne sont pas des objets de
divertissement et que ça ne concerne pas
que les cirques itinérants
donc les ya pas que les animaux sauvages
vous avez vous avez plein d'animaux qui
ne sont pas considérés comme sauvage est
qu'ils sont victimes
enfin non pas de maltraitance mais
d'enfermement qui n'ont rien à faire
dans les cirques on va s'intéresser à
présent à votre programme pour les cinq
prochaines années et d'abord au droit le
parti animalistes compte beaucoup
d'avocats vous en faites partie vous
souhaitez créer un code de la protection
animale regroupant l'ensemble des
dispositions protégeant les animaux
alors et depuis ça c'était effectivement
à l'époque depuis ce code il a été créé
il existe mais c'est pas un code
officiel mais il existe vous aviez marre
guaino avec 30 millions d'amis qui a
créé ce code d'ailleurs que j'ai et que
j'ai que j'ai qui regroupe toutes les
toutes les dispositions existantes mais
il ne change en rien c'est juste pour
faciliter le travail de l'avocat nous ce
qu'on souhaite c'est effectivement un
changement complet celle créée avait
créé un véritable statut de l'animal là
et puis surtout créer aussi un véritable
statut de l'animal sauvage qui n'est pas
pris en compte par la protection du code
pénal voilà dont six au rang dans les
détails mais aussi très très insuffisant
il faut vraiment créer un statut
juridique voire même une personnalité
juridique de l'animal mais là je vais
vous perdre si je rentre dans les
détails il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
parce que même si en 2015 on a considéré
que les animaux étaient des êtres
vivants sensible et que cela était
intégré dans le code civil loin derrière
ça n'a pas suivi ça a été plus
symbolique qu'autre chose puisque les
animaux sont restés dans la catégorie en
tout cas dans le code civil dans la
catégorie des biens et que c'est très
compliqué aujourd'hui de deux si on n'a
pas un statut juridique vient en fait
cette phrase que les animaux sont des
êtres sensibles à ces nuls belles
phrases mais elle n'est pas suivie dans
les actes vous souhaitez aussi la
création d'un ministère de la protection
animale aujourd'hui c'est une
prérogative du ministère de
l'agriculture alors vous nous dites
qu'il ya un conflit d'intérêts pourquoi
rien confie l'intérêt puisque au jour
d'aujourd'hui vous avez donc vous avez
donc le ministre de l'agriculture qui
travaille avec la fnsea et c'est donc on
c'est bon on sait c'est de notoriété
publique lorsqu'un ministre de
l'agriculture est désigné bon le
présidence assure quand même que la
fnsea les miens 1 donc je vois pas
comment on peut être alors on des
éleveurs qui vont hurler en disant mais
non mais nous on peut voit l'on peut pas
être on peut pas être juge et partie
donc on souhaite séparer d'une part le
ministre de l'agriculture et d'autre
part créer un ministre un ministère de
la condition animale demain de manière à
ce qu'ils aient pas de conflit
d'intérêts parce que là on le voit on a
le ministre de l'agriculture qui passe
son temps à dire le foie gras c'est bien
manger de la viande
voilà donc non c'est pas possible
pour mieux traiter les infractions
envers les animaux proposé la mise en
place de toute une logistique unités de
police départemental dédié à la
protection animale parquet spécialisé
pour la justice créé une autorité
administrative indépendante ayant un
droit de visite inopinée notamment dans
les élevages et des abattoirs une sorte
dit gpn mais pour les animaux et enfin
il y aurait la création d'un délit de
non dénonciation d'infractions commises
envers les animaux alors y at il déjà un
autre pays qui est aussi avant ciel
sont les mesures de notre programme de
notre ancien programme donc elles seront
sans doute peut-être développé un petit
peu modifié et vous avez des pays qui
sont plus avancés que nous vous avez
l'allemagne vous avez la suisse la
suisse on a causé même dans la
constitution en fait ce qui est
important c'est que nous on souhaiterait
que la cause animale soit
constitutionnel c'est-à-dire que la
protection animale entre dans la
constitution comme elle a été en suisse
dans la constitution dit que l'animal a
le droit à une dignité l'allemagne la
belgique la belgique a déjà 2 2 ministre
de la condition animale
l'espagne est en passe de se considérer
que les animaux domestiques sont membres
sont des membres de la famille à part
entière et qu'en cas de divorce et bien
si les époux le souhaitent ils peuvent
avoir un droit de visite donc oui on est
on est en retard par rapport à beaucoup
d'autres pays européens mais
beaucoup de pays mais l'europe
d'ailleurs a fait beaucoup a fait
beaucoup pour les animaux c'est là que
sans l'europe je pense que la france
elle sera encore très en retard en
parlons maintenant de l'alimentation le
budget de la pac politique agricole
commune de l'union européenne représente
environ un tiers du budget total ça
représente donc énormément d'argent vous
souhaitez que ce budget favorise
davantage une agriculture favorable bien
être des animaux aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qui vous dérange le plus avec le modèle
actuel alors déjà donc la pac
effectivement tenir le programme
européen parce que là ça concerne et ça
concerne l europe mais ce qui nous ce
qui nous dérange aujourd'hui la mesure
phare en ce qui concerne l'alimentation
c'est la fin de l'élevage intensif donc
la fin de l'élevage intensif une fois
qu'on a dit ça il faut pouvoir dire
comment on va procéder donc déjà on
souhaiterait que ça soit dans les cinq
ans et puis ça implique
ça il faut le dire ça implique une
diminution de la production et de la
consommation des protéines animales d'au
moins 50% pour cela il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui bien on propose
d'accompagner parce qu'en fait vous avez
et les nouilles qui régulièrement va
visiter des bavoirs des éleveurs
récemment l'état les dents dans un
élevage intensif de lapin
l'éleveur lui a dit d'ailleurs ça a été
filmé les verts lui a dit mais toute
façon ces palaces obligé pas le choix on
m'a imposé ce modèle dont vous avez
beaucoup d'éleveurs qui ne vivent même
pas de ce qu'ils font les ce qui se
passe envers les animaux est déplorable
donc nous on propose en fait d'aider les
éleveurs qui le souhaiteraient à se
reconvertir vers du végétal à l'échelle
européenne également vous souhaitez bien
que poussé la population vers une
alimentation plus végétal justement
réduction de 40% je ne sais pas si à
l'échelle européenne - là on est dans la
présidentielle mais il est évident que
vous savez il ya d'autres partis
animalistes en europe on a une dizaine
de partis animalistes donc il faut c'est
vrai que pour que ça c'est pour que ça
marche si on commence en france bien
évidemment il faudrait que tous les
autres pays européens s'y mettre parce
que si on dit que la fin d'élevage
intensif
ça c'est bon pour les animaux c'est bon
pour la santé humaine c'est bon pour la
pour eux pour l'environnement il faut
bien évidemment que ça soit que ça soit
appliquée dans d'autres pays mais comme
là pour l'instant nous sommes dans le
cadre d'une campagne présidentielle on
parle de la france mais bien évidemment
et un programme monsieur voilà
européenne pour vous quelle est
l'importance de l'union européenne à
l'union européenne comme si on
l'expliquer en fait c'est l'union
européenne les mesures les plus
favorables aux animaux qui ont été
prises par la france c'est parce qu'elle
n'avait pas le choix elles ont été
prises en fait par l'union européenne
alors pour finir cette émission nous
allons évoquer les animaux dans le
domaine de l'éducation et de la
formation vous souhaitez intégrer dans
les programmes scolaires des cours
d'initiation à l'éthologie alors qu'est
ce que c'est alors justement pourront
revenir dans la loi vous aviez tout à
l'heure par les la ppl animaux il est
prévu effectivement des cours de
sensibilisation
dans les écoles mais on ne sait pas
comment comment ça va être dispensé par
qui et c'est donc nous on considère en
fait que
que les années 20 on fait ce qu'on veut
s'étendre étendre notre considération à
tous les êtres vivants et donc
appartement on est capable de faire du
mal un être vivant quels qu'ils soient
aussi petit qu'il soit ça veut dire
qu'après et bien on peut faire du mal à
tous les autres êtres vivants donc il
est important de pouvoir dès l'enfance
sensibilité sensibiliser les enfants au
respect des êtres vivants donc il
faudrait après on verra effectivement
avec mine isolée pain avec les
professeurs comment on peut intégrer
mais oui ça serait indispensable qui est
l'enseignement de l'éthique j'ai l'air
de l'empathie je ne sais pas si ça
s'enseigne mais en même temps si de ce
que les enfants soient sensibilisés
cercle qu'ils apprennent que muse la
tranche 2 horno au moins aussi que la
tranche de jambon sous plastique qu'ils
mangent basse et babe le cochon vous
voyez donc les sensibiliser à ça peut
être aussi faire des cours de cuisine
apprendre aux enfants qui d'ailleurs est
aux adultes à cuisiner autrement que la
viande et les protéines animales donc
oui c'est très important parce que c'est
j'allais dire c'est la base il faut
commencer il faut commencer à enseigner
l'éthique aux plus jeunes dès le plus
jeune âge dans votre programme on trouve
aussi une interdiction des dissections
donc de primaire et dans le secondaire
alors plus de dissection de souris au
collège au jour d'aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de 2,2
l'application qui travaillent qui font
des dissections n'a plus besoin on n'a
plus besoin de tuer des animaux pour
pouvoir disséquer on a des logiciels on
a des très performant des images en 3d
enfin ces voix là on n'a plus besoin de
ça en sachant que les animaux sont tués
alors effectivement maintenant le
rapport plus vivants mais ils sont tués
avant pour ça donc oui enfin développer
les modules de formation aux droits des
animaux dans les facs de droit là aussi
donc c'est en cohérence avec toutes les
modifications que vous souhaitez
apporter dans le droit animal c'est la
côte est alors ça c'est pareil c'était
en 2016 depuis il ya eu beaucoup de il
ya eu beaucoup de fac il ya eu beaucoup
d'universités qui ont créé des 10 août
et de droit animal donc ça a commencé à
bouger avec des professeurs de droit qui
étaient intéressés donc ça a bougé mais
faudrait continuer faudrait
effectivement que ce soit ça tout à fait
sur le programme du parti animalis mme
on l'a eu il est amené à être un peu
modifié sur quels sujets vous travaillez
à qui on travaille sur tous les sujets
étaient sur toutes les thématiques qu'on
travaille sur le droit animal on
travaille sur les animaux d'élevage on
travaille sur le divertissement mais on
travaille aussi sur gras tout un
chapitre démocratie puisque le rics
contre le principe du riq sera dans
notre programme on travaille aussi sur
sur les ehpad c'est à dire qu'en fait la
cause animale elle elle débouche en fait
sur surtout ça ne concerne pas que les
animaux par exemple on voudrait que les
ehpad accepte que parce que déjà c'est
difficile vous êtes placé dans une
maison de retraite est souvent ce sont
des personnes qui sont seules qui vivent
avec un chat et un chien et l'a non
seulement les places elles quittent
leurs maisons melki leur animal de
compagnie donc on souhaiterait notamment
c'est un exemple que les ehpad puisse
accueillir les animaux de leurs
pensionnaires sur les associations qui
nous protège les animaux plus de
subventions plus fin plus d'être plus de
ses effectifs en plus de reconnaissance
pour les associations qui apportent la
preuve qu'elles font un travail
remarquable et puis surtout moins de
flicage entre guillemets parce que
j'aurais quand même parler de la loi
d'émetteurs qui acquit à bien viser
toutes ces associations et qui avait
pour but d'entraver d'entravé voilà au
début c'était c'est le prétexte était
il faut faire attention aux activistes
entre guillemets mais ça concernait à
peine 0 3% et donc maintenant c'est toi
d'émetteurs qui a donc et une loi qui a
été créé sur l'initiative du
gouvernement de la fnsea du ministre de
l'agriculture est bien donne des
prérogatives
à la police pour arrêter donc on a
notamment par exemple les échos les
coprésidents les cofondateurs de l214
qui ont été interviewés et cetera qui
sont suivies donc on aimerait bien aussi
l'abolition de cette loi et puis surtout
la protection des lanceurs d'alerté
qui sont essentielles à cette démocratie
et enfin pour finir sur la question des
abandons plus de plus de sanctions plus
de sanctions mais en même temps j'allais
dire l'abandon il est déjà sanctionné
aujourd'hui il faut travailler en amont
donc c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure stérilisation des chats errants
plus d'animaux dans les dents les dans
les animaleries donc il faut travailler
en amont parce que si les gens à voilà
si les gens n'achetaient pas sur un coup
de tête n'importe comment bien gréement
d'abandon il faut aussi travailler sur
une mutualisation peut être trouvé un
système ce que les frais de vétérinaires
sont très chers donc voilà il ya plein
de choses mais je pense que à
sanctionner l'abandon c'est bien mais
nous on veut travailler parce que je
crois que l'europe de la france et le
champion d'europe des abandons et après
les présidentielles la présidentielle il
y aura le juste car oui alors il a conçu
des ajustements donc je nous sommes
nombreux au parc animalista se présenter
on souhaite mettre des candidats dans
toutes les circonscriptions on a lancé
un appel à toutes les personnes qui sont
sensibles à la cause animale donc si
vous souhaitez vous présenter comme
candidat aux législatives pour le parti
animalistes et bien vous aurez vous avez
un formulaire vous allez sur le site du
parc animalistes et vous trouverez le
formulaire donc on a besoin de vous on a
besoin d'hommes aussi parce qu'aux
dernières législatives il y en avait
présenté plus de femmes que d'hommes et
sur notre financement public on a eu une
pénalité de 30% merci beaucoup catherine
helayel d'avoir évidemment avec nous
dans l'hebdo politique je rappelle que
vous êtes la porte parole du parti
animalistes et nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de l'hebdo politique très bonne soirée à
tous sur radio sensations
[Musique]
les taux politique